[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a comedy short film called
alternative math
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in a
post-fact american society where
everything you say has to align with
everyone else's opinion in an elementary
school math teacher mrs wells invites a
student danny to her class
danny has failed his recent math test
terribly and is very mad about it
however he isn't mad that he didn't do
well on the test instead he is bothered
by the teacher who gave him bad grades
and said all of his answers were wrong
dany shows mrs wells his answer sheet
full of red markings and a big f on the
top the teacher calmly takes a look at
his paper and explains that his answers
are wrong seeing that the kid has
written 2 plus 2 is equal to twenty-two
it is clear that he is having some
trouble with addition or maybe he's a
goddamn genius being the good teacher
that she is mrs wells asks the boy to
not be upset because it is normal for
kids his age to be confused by numbers
she explains that he is here to learn
and that making mistakes is part of the
learning experience but by the look on
dany's face her kind words went over his
head he expresses his confusion with a
sassy
to his teacher's face mrs wells remains
composed and asks him to look at the
questions again she points out his
obvious mistake but danny seems to be
uninterested mrs walls further explains
that two plus two doesn't equal 22
because addition doesn't mean you can
just put the numbers next to each other
you have to add them
as she explains how he can add the
numbers the kid scoffs and says that her
method is stupid the woman manages to
suppress her frustration and tries
giving him a practical example she
brings out two markers in each of her
hands and puts them together asking the
kid how many markers she has in total
with all the sass he can gather danny
replies that the answer is 22 finally
starting to get irritated mrs wells
tells him he is wrong and the obvious
answer is four the spoiled kid pushes
the box of markers off the desk and
storms out of the classroom in anger mrs
wells is left speechless by the kid's
behavior but she doesn't think much of
it until the very next day when his
parents come to her classroom with a
complaint at first they introduce
themselves politely and take a seat at
mrs wells's request before the parents
can voice their concerns the teacher
assures them that there is nothing to
worry about she further adds that it is
completely normal for kids like danny to
get frustrated when they are struggling
with a subject especially a subject like
math where they can hardly use their
creativity danny's mother doesn't seem
to be grateful for mrs wells's kind
words after all the apple doesn't fall
far from the she ignores
everything the teacher says and asks why
dany is getting some answers wrong in
her so-called test mrs wells is taken
aback by the rudeness but doesn't show
it in her face she composes herself and
starts explaining what kinds of
questions were on the test after she
states that dany's answer to the
question what is 2 plus 2 was 22 the
room goes silent one might think the
parents realized that it was their son's
mistake but to mrs wells's surprise they
asked her to go on waiting for her to
prove her point it becomes clear that
the couple doesn't understand that the
kid's answer is wrong the teacher
bluntly says that 22 is not the right
answer the mother in utter disbelief
asks mrs wells who says that the answer
is wrong mrs wells replies that is how
math works the couple misses the whole
point and accuses mrs wells of calling
their son stupid the teacher explains
that it was not her intention and that
she is simply trying to correct his
mistake things get heated when the dad
starts to yell he asks mrs wells who she
is to declare his son's answer is wrong
and hers is right mrs wells is in
complete shock at the stupidity of the
couple she tries to reason with them
stating that the answers are factual and
they would never change the mother acts
like she understands mrs wells words but
then accuses her of being a nazi and
forcing absolute answers on her child
confused by everything the teacher
bluntly asks the two if they know what
two plus two equals instead of an answer
mrs wells gets insults thrown at her the
father calls her a smart ass then
mocks her accent their politeness from a
while ago vanishes into thin air as they
get more and more aggressive still being
respectful mrs wells tells them that she
can no longer continue the conversation
and shows them the way out danny's
mother claims that they are going to
complain to the principal while his
father shouts his son is a free thinker
for saying the answer is 22 before
leaving the mother threatens to get her
kicked out of the job and calls her a
having had enough of the two mrs
wells sarcastically shames them for not
knowing what two plus two is the scene
abruptly ends as the mother slaps mrs
wells on her face the following day the
principal comes to mrs wells's class to
discuss the matter he immediately gets
to the point and asks her what the issue
was with danny's parents mrs wells
announces that it got a little crazy
because the parents weren't cooperating
she inquires how the management is
handling the situation only to find out
that they want her to apologize to the
parents this makes her mad because the
mother was the one who hit her the
principal has a problem with mrs wells
telling the kids that their answer is
wrong a confused mrs wells says that it
is her job as a teacher to tell them
when they make mistakes however the
principal doesn't share the same view he
claims that the teachers should not ram
their biased views down the students
throats because the students have their
own opinions in the new and modernized
world everything has to be politically
correct it is wrong to declare a kid's
answer incorrect just because of your
opinion mrs wells is left stunned she
claims that math cannot be biased
because it is factual the principal
starts getting annoyed and says that mrs
wells attitude is making the situation
worse he scornfully tells her that she
is giving the children zero respect
which is against their school's policies
that day a crowd of parents assembles in
front of the school and protests against
the teacher's absolute behavior mrs
wells is shoved by the crowd who asks
her to stop undermining their kid's
confidence some of them even demand that
she apologize to the parents she
offended by claiming that two plus two
is four things get worse when they
accuse her of hating children in general
sensing the situation getting more
serious the school's superintendent and
his counsel hold a meeting with mrs
wells she nervously asks the board of
men to wait for a week or two for the
situation to blow over but the
superintendent claims they cannot wait
because the parents are suing the school
for emotional distress to a minor mrs
wells exclaims that she only said two
plus two is four which shouldn't have
caused this much trouble the board
members scoff at the comment and reply
that she should admit the possibility of
multiple correct answers to the same
question mrs wells is in absolute
disbelief she knows that she is right
but the world seems to have changed to a
weird place where every answer must be
true and every fact is debatable the
principal accuses her of portraying
everyone who disagrees with her as
stupids when mrs wells stays put in her
opinion the board members suspend her
and ask her to reconsider her extremist
views if she ever wants to get her job
back the next day mrs wells packs up all
of her belongings from the school and
returns home at night she watches the tv
and finds out that the scandal has made
the national television many political
leaders are debating if two plus two
equals 22 or four the media exaggerates
the news and calls mrs wells an activist
who was caught abusing a kid's first
amendment rights she is being called a
liberal elitist for saying that for is
the definitive answer to the simple
question some even belittle mrs wells
for not keeping the students in her
class for more than a year to which mrs
wells angrily says it's called
graduating
while she is watching the news annoyed
at the stupidity of the reporters she
gets a call from the school the
principal informs her that she has
officially been fired he also asks her
to come by the school the next day and
requests that she stop radicalizing the
students the following day mrs wells
goes to school for the last time as she
walks through the entrance she is
greeted by a group of reporters
patiently waiting for her the school has
invited them to prove they do not
support mrs walls extremist view and to
make it clear she is no longer their
employee before officially signing the
papers and ending her contract with the
school the principal says he will pay
her the monthly salary for the last two
terms the salary rounds up to two
thousand dollars for the last month and
two thousand for this one the principal
says that is four thousand dollars in
total but at last mrs wells claps back
and claims it is actually twenty two
thousand dollars the movie ends as the
principal awkwardly looks towards the
reporters and back at a smiling mrs
wells
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching